so what what we're working on is on the
body contact okay so I I don't care how
how you how you got there with your over
under okay but when you get when you get
here it's my body that does it I'm not
going to move around on this one okay so
when you get here my body does it you
see it my body turned him I didn't move
okay and then same thing over here I
don't want to use my hands because I'm
gonna create
space so he's trying to frame or
whatever you're GNA try to frame him and
punch you in the face okay as he's
trying to frame look how I'm using my
body shoulder chin head and I slip in
there was no space boom got it so again
here not like this it's not going to be
there okay keeping keeping weight on him
I'm using my body get your arm
out do you see yes sir get your arm out
got it get my space get myself where I
need to be without creating any
space okay it's totally different all
right try it get the whole person not
just the little camera
effect okay so again not not important
how you got to your over not important
okay what we're looking for is that we
have pressure and I'm not creating space
to move his body there's the lock right
away do one more time I'm I'm going to
look for the lock now in transition I'm
I'm already thinking about that lock
okay boom there it is do you see and I
move him and this left left arm boom
lands right on it got it okay then we'll
do the next one going come across change
push close off that angle
cancellation there it is right there so
this is going to go under I'm already
looking for it get your arm
out you
see finish boom
in
so it's trapped long before I'm grabbing
it right yes
sir there's something to understand on
on on locks in idealized environment so
if if I was going to do Nel Niko can't
be on when my hand goes down okay uh
Niko's already on n's already on try to
stand
up do you get it it's not I don't go
here and then go down you see how it's
off and then on as soon as I come it's
on it's on right away if I'm going to do
katame same thing here it's not off and
then on okay so if I'm if I'm here it's
on already even even if it looks like
it's not completed it's on already okay
if I'm going to do Kama again as I'm
working it it's already on so that I
don't have to do these movements do you
see right as we land he wanted to tap
okay so same
thing if I'm
working this lock if I make these if I
have to make these big gross movements
then it's not going to it's not ideal
okay so let's say he's pushing on me
right and as I'm working that same body
it's it's already on which I won't do
the mat part but it's on already do you
see yes sir so when I get here that's
why you notice that I didn't really move
and it's already
on you don't have to do these big
movements save that for when it counts
okay but when you're idealized
environment you you should be tight at
contact and it's only getting tighter
without the movement going on okay all
right